le yukon est un endroit dangereux
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
je suis monté ici parce que je ne
voulais plus côtoyé personnes et puis
j'ai rencontré boc
[Musique]
c'était un chien différent des autres il
avait été gâté
[Musique]
bien et il avait souffert
mais on ne pouvait pas le briser
je ne sais pas d'où tu viens
je sais où tu aujourd'hui bienvenue au
bout du bout du monde on va lui laisser
une minute je crois qu'il n'a encore
jamais vu de neige
ça tirait de tenter l aventure
au delà des cartes on pourrait aller toi
et moi
là où personne n'est encore allé voir ce
qu'il y à là bas
[Musique]
quantum ça te plaise
je n'ai jamais dit croire en quoi que ce
soit autant qu'il croit en toi
tandis que web
celle aventures d'une vie
bien dormir pendant deux jours dans mon
lit
[Musique]